I'm so sick of looking at Absolute
horror on the internet and people
getting away with it much less being
celebrated for it Marin Morris with a
strong message for Jason Aldean's wife
Brittany after getting into it over
their positions on trans rights it was
just like I didn't really think I woke
up and chose violence today it all
started when Britney showed this video
showing her before and after glam
[Music]
in the caption she writes I'd really
like to thank my parents for not
changing my gender when I went through
my tomboy phase I love this girly life
that started a mixed string of reactions
Madison Lacroix RaeLynn and Laura Trump
showed their support but Cassidy Pope
she firmly disagreed writing you'd think
celebs with Beauty Brands would see the
positives including lgbtq plus people in
their messaging but instead here we are
hearing someone compare their tomboy
phase to someone wanting to transition
real nice I wish I could bring you down
[Music]
Marin saw Cassidy's comment and wasted
no time adding her two cents strong
words again aimed at Britain it's so
easy to like not be a scumbag human sew
your clip-ins and zip it in surrection
Barbie oof and it didn't take long
before both Marin and Brittany's
husband's weighed in Brittany's husband
Jason played off Marin's dig and called
Brittany my Barbie meanwhile maron's man
Ryan Hurd addressed the drama on Twitter
with a lengthy message praising his wife
for sticking up for others and dissing
Brittany for her comments quote scoring
quick points by picking on trans kids
isn't something that is brave at all I
think it's cool to like know where you
stand with somebody yeah and that that's
a really neat thing but despite all the
back and forth drama Britney's still
doubling down on her stance writing on
her Instagram story some parents want to
be accepted by Society so badly that
they're willing to make life-altering
decisions for their children who aren't
old enough to fully comprehend the
consequences of those actions and Marin
she's not done yet either y'all have
been so sweet and supportive today
um of me and Cassidy I will say like we
can handle this we've dealt with idiots
you know for years you know saying
insanely stupid stuff at us but like I
check on your trans Friends check on
your gay friends anyone that like is in
country music and had to look at that
both today and feel
subhuman Maron showed E.T that same fire
in April at the Grammys when she opened
up about the importance of inclusivity
especially in country music you have
been so outspoken about diversity in
country music and now we are really
seeing it you're one of the people who
helped push it Forward what does it mean
to you now well I mean it's not just me
like it's it's a lot of our friends that
believe in that and so yeah looking at
the representation getting better in the
genre is is so special so I feel like I
just I'm sort of like a byproduct of it
I'm not the cause but I I'm just so
proud of where it's headed
[Music]
thank you